Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the outline for this
series of courses.
And then we're going to jump right in and take a look at the concept of a one texture
packing method when building worlds for games.
So let's get started.
You'll see here first, we'll talk about the one texture equation.
And that's basically masking of our materials using one texture to be able to do so.
We'll also look at Nanite and a review of how to use it.
We'll look at PCGs, blueprints and foliage tool, using PCGs, making blueprints and foliage
quicktake.
We'll look at level instancing impact level actors when it comes to building your world.
We'll then look at a quick landscape quicktake.
And then we'll look at world partition, an overview of it.
We'll look at editing tools, we'll look at basic planning concepts, and then we'll
look at material optimization, and finally some tips, tricks and plugins.
Now keep in mind, a lot of what we're talking about already exists in many of our other
classes.
And this is an overview when it comes to the concept of building your world with
games and using these tools holistically, as well as some of them getting a little
bit deeper than normal, such as when it comes to the texture equation.
We're going to look at that a bit deeper, and we're going to see what we can do
with that particular tool.
So let's get started.
So the one texture equation.
This is very important when it comes to your world.
If you want to be able to have a bit of overhead management, and make it so they don't
have too many textures loading in your scene.
You can do this with maybe one texture pack.
If it's a smaller game, if it's a larger game, you can have several of these textures
packed in your RGB channels.
Let me show you what I mean.
If you look at a regular texture, you'll see that it has its RGB channels in place.
But what you can do creatively is go into Photoshop, and you can paint on each one of those channels,
getting the color information that you need, as well as getting in here and painting on
such channels, such as the red channel for your roughness, as well as the alpha.
You can paint alpha information and isolate it within that alpha channel.
Let's go and jump into Unreal, and I'll show you this up close.
In Unreal, we're in our startup map here, and I'm going to show you a little bit of
how this is all broken down when it comes to using one texture in your packing of
your RGBs.
So if I go ahead and click on, say, this little object here that has a texture on it,
I'm going to click on the mGen material, and I'm going to double click on that.
Let me pull this over.
Now you'll see in our scene here, we have a simple texture setup.
I'm going to go ahead and go to that texture.
I'm going to double click on it, and I'm going to bring this over into our area,
our work area here.
And you can see we have red, green, and blue, as well as alpha, and all of them
are on at this time.
Now, if I wanted to, I can go in here and isolate and say, I just want to use the red
channel.
You'll see that I've painted and created a rough, tileable texture that I can use
and plug into my rough channels if I need to.
I can also turn on the green channel, and I can also turn on rough at the same time
if I wanted a little bit of a different color.
And then I can even go in there and mess with my chroma key if I wanted to.
I could even mess with my vibrance within that texture.
And when you do that, you want to make sure you make a copy of the texture if you do that,
or build it within the material where you can control those values, which actually works
out pretty well.
I can go to the B channel here, and if I wanted a bump map or displacement, I can
do so.
And the green channel isolated could also be a mild occlusion map if I wanted.
And then we also have alpha.
So I could turn that off, and you could see that I have alpha maps that I can use
and put them on simple pieces of geometry.
Now keep in mind when you're using simple pieces of geometry, and say you're not using
decals in this particular case, because using this with decals is really tricky and virtually
impossible unless you know exactly where things are placed.
But I've put these on certain small pieces of geometry that do not create a shadow.
You might want to make it so that that particular object or that simple piece of geometry,
there isn't a lot of them in your scene.
Because with simple pieces of geometry, and you're using Lumen, and you're using Nanite,
you want to make it so that you're not making Nanite kind of slow down when you
have simple pieces of geometry in your scene.
Now I'll re-emphasize that later, because what you can do is you can also make it
so that that piece of simple geometry is bumped up to have higher geometry, which will
make Nanite happier and make it so we have less hits on our calculations, because it's
constantly looking for the higher poly, but if you have lower poly and you have too many
lower poly in your scene, and you're trying to convert those to Nanite, you could run
into performance issues.
So we'll talk a little bit about that later on.
I'll repeat myself on that, but it's just something to keep in mind.
But in our case, I just have a few simple pieces of geometry with these little symbols
on here and warning signs, and it's pretty manageable at that point.
Let's go ahead and go back into Unreal real quick.
So what we can do is take a look at, let's say this one right here.
Now this particular piece of geometry, let's go and look at his material.
Let's go and pull that material back over here.
You'll notice that we have an albedo set up, a metal, normal.
We also have an ORMD, and you'll hear that phrase quite often.
That's your occlusion, your rough, your metal, and diffuse.
It could probably easily be O-R-M-A if you wanted to.
You could do whatever you want for that acronym, but I just kept it kind of standard.
And then we have specular.
So all of these are controllable within this material itself.
And if I wanted to, I can also change the color information.
So if I wanted that color to change, I could do so.
And that makes it pretty easy because I haven't built it into the material.
But let's look at the material close and look at those connections.
Now I kept it pretty simple.
It might look like a little bit of a noodle fest, but it's pretty simplistic, where you
can find where there's the rough connection.
There is the green channel going into the multiply for metallic.
And then we also have the bead channel, which is going up into our lerp, as well
as into our base blend overlay, so that we can have a bit of a color control when
it comes to our overall look for this guy for the albedo tint.
So and then down below, it's pretty straightforward.
We have our standard normal map in here.
Now this can be a simple going into a multiply.
I have it so that if I wanted to invert it, I have the option to do so.
So that's in there.
So you can see it's pretty standard stuff from actually accessing each one of those channels
that we talked about.
And each one of those channels, again, allows me to be able to build out and create and
isolate what I need to isolate.
You can actually see this here a bit closer when you look at the alpha two, you'll see
that there's an alpha present over here.
And I'm activating and using that alpha specifically.
And you can see here I have it active.
I'm even having the patterns in some of the materials for the alpha to make it look
like it's analyzing a terrain or some computer readouts are going on, and even scrolling
some of the text.
So it can actually come in pretty handy.
You'll notice also in my alpha, I have some textures.
Now this one has a normal map on it's going to turn that off for a second.
I just want to show you that you have the option to do so if you want to double click
on that again.
There we go.
Let me pull this over.
You'll notice having normal maps, so let's go and disconnect that normal map for a second.
Hit the Alt key and left click and I'll hit apply.
And I think I have that pretty much active for the keyboard, but in this particular
case, we don't need it.
So down below, you'll see as we play with these, you can go in here and let's pull
this over for a second here and I can choose to animate any one of these.
And I even have textured ones in here and banding that we can use when it comes
to like adding a holographic projection.
Now this one, I just literally use the original it came with, but I gave the option
if someone wanted to, they could go in here and grab some of these texture items and put
a nice degrading gradient in here and make it so that it has a holographic projection
to it, which is actually pretty cool.
So there's a lot of packing and adjusting.
You just have to figure out what you need and how you need it.
You can see I have all sorts of options and you'll see this panel work here is actually
down here.
You can just be as creative as you need to just making sure that you set things up ahead
of time.
And it really does when using this method, it really does take a lot of thought ahead
You have to think ahead of what you need, what you want, what resolution you need.
And you can see some of these are a little bit lower on the low side when it comes to
resolution and um, you can determine in your little a sheet that you make for it, what
is going to require larger, um, resolution based on what you are, how you're building
your world.
So it's really nice to be able to create it and let me actually look and show you
a demonstration of it in place in a whole little environment here.
So let's go ahead and control, let's move this out of the way for a second.
Let's go and control our exposure and you can see my trim sheet.
I have a lot of options in this particular case, let's go and bump up the exposure
just a little bit.
We're cheating.
I'm not putting the actual lights in here right now, but you can see we have a nice
little environment.
We have tubing that all has the same texture.
These all have the same texture.
All of these primarily have the same texture, just maybe a few added pieces such as this
screen here that I added and this little scope as well as a little bit of a, um,
occlusion parallax occlusion on some of these buttons.
But overall they're pretty much using the same texture through and through.
I'm a bit of a Mobius fan, I work with him at my twenties, so, um, and also a Jack Kirby
fan, huge fan of his work when he was around and even after my aging myself a little
bit maybe.
But you can see some really cool effects and looks and visuals that you can get from
this all from this one texture trim sheet that I created.
And we can go ahead and pair things together and no one really is the wiser.
It's actually pretty great.
And you'll see some of the pipes here too, just have a simple rough, um, uh, texture in
here using that rough channel that I already painted and putting it into the pipes.
Awesome.
So that's it for this course.
In the next course, we're going to go and break down a few things such as using Nanite
and a little brief peek into blueprints, which we'll cover later on.
Awesome.
Thanks again.